[Music]
as someone who is a physicist but also
thinks in more philosophical terms what
exists is not only physical if you want
to say what existed is a big mistake to
say that only physical things exist and
so what does I mean we do not be
intimidated by a reductionist into
agreeing that it's only particles and
forces that exist because that isn't
true
ideas exist and so all right you may say
this involves the brain and it's a
complex thing so instead let me to say
the following example algorithms exist
an algorithm is a procedure which is
used in computers in order to create
things for instance most of the motor
cars that you drive around and they are
created in factories because an
algorithmic directing what happens in
the factory and that is the reason that
the motor car exists now what is an
algorithm made of is it made of wood or
concrete or particles of some kind the
answer is an algorithm is an abstract
entity it is realized in various ways in
these computers and then through that
realization it causes motorcars to come
into existence because they wouldn't
exist if it wasn't for the album but the
algorithm itself is an abstract entity
so if you want to describe why things
exist not only do you have to think
about why particles exist and forces
because you've also got to think about
why abstract entities exists and I can
give you many other examples with my
concrete immediate example as algorithms
which undoubtedly exist they undoubtedly
have causal power in the real world as
it exists today for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
institute of arts and ideas at iai TV
you